it's in his right pocket
stop fuck
[Music]
9-1-1 where's your emergency
705 south new road shot has been fired
the guy has a gun in my store 705 south
new road
yes i just called you
how many shots has anybody been injured
nobody's injured we all ran he's still
in the store
he's in the store
yes
i need offices here now they're on the
way has anybody been injured
no can everybody get out
everybody got out
ma'am
yeah she said they're saying 705 but
that's not in my cat i have 600
something 705 south who wrote it
you're an absent
yes
okay all right stay on the phone let me
transfer you to speaking
oh that's right man stay on the phone
stay on the phone
there's customers going for zoning oh my
god are you coming ma'am
abseek and this is your dollar general
shots have been fired inside for a male
trying to steal cars he's inside talk to
the dispatcher
705 south new road yes abc
9-1-1 where is your emergency
705 south new york but i have a guy
that's trying to steal cars
and
he's coming back in the store he just
tried to steal a customer's car
705 south new road new road yeah
and what is there a business
it's a dollar general
okay
and he's standing at his i don't know
how is he trying to steal their cars he
just jumped in their car if he had the
the owner ripped him out and now he's
standing in front of my building
and with his hands up i don't i don't
know he's not mentally stable i would
assume but he literally just jumped in
his car and tried to steal it what's he
look like
he's a black male wearing all black he
has braids in his hair
he's about six foot
i'm on the phone with the cops
and
he tried to jump in someone's car
yeah the guy is still right here yeah he
jumped in the car the guy ripped him out
of his car absolutely did
i have it on camera
and he's like he's he's watching
everybody what's your name
lori
okay
all right is this your phone number
yes it is
yes
all right
they're on their way thank you
anybody shooting here
put your hands up
one at gunpoint
keep your hands up
looks like a fake gun in his pocket it's
going to be jalil with it
have him at gunpoint now stop stop stop
shoot stop
stop
stop turn around please stop
please please
in california
oh
[Music]
stop stop
stop
[Music]
drop to your knees stop drop stop knees
do not reach
sir do not reach do not reach
just on the ground
please please sorry listen it's not
working it's not
just get down
just drop to your knees
just drop to your knees sir please
no please no do it
we don't want to do that you don't want
it don't stop stop
please
please please please please please
no no no no no no we don't want to do
that
we don't want to do that
okay you gonna drop the phone
no no no no stop
no
no please
stop
please stop stop stop please all right
that's a good fight
[Music]
oh
just turn around brother please please
turn around please please yeah i got
listen i'm here with you i'm here with
you just turn around for us just turn
around for us sir please please stop
please please please please please just
turn around
just stop no we're not we don't want to
shoot you stop
please we do not want to shoot you
we do not want to shoot you back up a
little bit brother back up back up back
up sir we do not want to shoot you
let's get a good backdrop
right here is a brick wall
brick wall good backdrop sir stop stop
please stop stop stop stop sir stop stop
stop
get on the ground
stop it do not reach
do not reach stop you don't want to do
this do not reach
do not reach straight
sir just get down to the ground
drop to your knees
do not reach
sir
it's not worth it it's not
just get down
just drop to your knees
just drop to your knees sir please
no please we don't want to do it
you don't we don't want to do that we
don't want to do that stop stop stop
please stop
please please please please please
please
no no no no no no no we don't want to do
that
we don't want to do that
okay
okay you going to drop the phone
no no no no no
no
no please please please please please
please stop
please stop stop stop stop stop
okay okay okay okay good that's a good
spot
that's a good spot gotcha
it's in his right pocket
don't reach no he's not reaching he's
not reaching it's not reaching
get on your stomach
oh you're stupid
[Applause]
[Music]
get on the ground
just drop it
come on just get on the ground
come on gillette you're all right
come on jalal
everything is okay jaleel
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
shots fired shots
[Music]
is fired your car
is that your car
get in the car
[Applause]
get in the freezer
get in your car
you got my phone who who is that i don't
know i can't i can't get that's your
phone yeah that's my phone i came to get
tampons okay you're good you're good
the answer call y'all
dr phone jaleel
drop the phone that's not your phone
drop it
on the ground oh my god
oh my god
stay right there
back back up back up
stand stay behind the engine of the car
don't do it jaleel don't do it
don't do it jaleel
one person talk one person talk
one person talk
put it on the card joel
[Music]
evans back up evans evans back up
evans back up
get covered evans get coming i got him
you see his hands
see his hands evan's back up behind
cover evans back up behind cover back up
behind cover
[Music]
no
[Applause]
drop the phone that's not your phone
drop it
get on the ground
what's on this right
back up
[Music]
one person taught
laid light in the fire move the line of
fire you in the line of fire
see his hands
up behind cover back up
[Applause]
get on the ground
don't reach
now
[Music]
worth it
please don't do it
[Music]
maze you move out of the way they're in
front of you
everything is okay
don't reach
now
[Applause]